the year 2019 the problem Mexico needs
trees the solution the sewing life
project a $3.4 billion program that pays
Farmers to plant fruit and Timber trees
on Barren land not only will this help
spruce up the environment but it will
fight poverty and inequality by paying
the farmers to maintain the new trees
sounds like a great idea with the best
of intentions what could possibly go
wrong it turns out poor Farmers need
money and since standing trees didn't
qualify for the program the system
incentivized Farmers to cut down mature
trees to make way for new ones in one
Village 2third of the program's
participants chop down forests to get
that cash one study found the program
caused the deforestation of more than
280 square miles but you know what they
say about the best laid
plants